donc j'étais une enfant adam alors ça
c'est moi alors qu'il doit même aidé à
faire un sketch ou syndicales
je lis quels sont les liens ou celle
immobile parce que sinon tu cherches pas
faire et oui et oui ça devait arriver
vous avez perdu votre place et vous
voici entre deux portes celle du bureau
dans le sens de la forte et l'autre
celle de la maison qu'il va falloir
pousser en annonçant la chose
ce qui n'est pas le plus simple tant il
est vrai qu'il est plus facile d'arriver
au bureau en racontant qu on est renvoyé
de la maison que de rentrer à la maison
en disant qu'on est renvoyé du bureau
non ne pas perdre la face devant madame
et les petits plusieurs formules par
exemple vous arrivez vous trouvez votre
épouse à ses travaux de couture vous
dites postone ouvrage fait les bagages
on part en vacances et si on fait une
réflexion bureau germées puis les plus
cheap
ou bien un peu mythomane mais sûr de
vous j'ai eu une altercation salée avec
bleustein blanchet il est cher monsieur
cette fois ci ça commence à bien faire
l'un de nos deux étant dans la maison
c'est vous ou moi il m'a dit d'accord
comme il a des charges familiales je
vais laisser la place ou peut-être en
donnant dans l'innocence chéri j'ai
besoin d'un petit conseil
on ne propose de rester au même poste
mais sans salaire et sans chaise pour
m'asseoir je crois pas qu'il ya un piège
là tout est maintenant vous pouvez
ramener la scène à tête à tête entre
vous et la mère de vos enfants vous lui
dites en rentrant d'un air dégagé et là
tu ne trouves pas la maison pendant que
moi je me change les idées avec les
copains du bureau dit alors voilà je
t'ai trouvé un job léger 20 heures
minuit tous les jours comme pompiste
chez i saw tu commence demain
qu'est ce qu'on dit qu'est ce qu'on voit
selon la nature de certains c'est de
l'aigreur l'affreuse erreur a
déconseillé bonsoir très bien merci
à propos depuis le temps que tu te
pleurniche pas ce qu'on peut changer les
week end le samedi réjouis toi
maintenant on peut partir le lundi soir
heureuse
pour un courant aussi mais aussi
discutable la mer injustice que
connaissent bien nos dab s'est tué le 16
août 1959 à la soirée du personnel quand
tu as refusé un tango au patron le 16
août 1959 et bien cet après-midi le
patron il m'a foutu à la porte
je remercie bras vous remercie son
commentaire en tout cas cette dernière
attitude également classique bien c'est
le moment de prendre mes responsabilités
j'ai déjà gâché les plus belles années
de ta jeunesse depuis six ans qu'on est
marié mais cela réussit cette heure que
les cinq mondes est le sixième est en
route cette fois ci j'ai décidé de me
conduire l'adulte je me tire enfin